hello everyone welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for its elitism
Rosa versus magnus carlsen and a lot of
you have suggested it as soon as it
finished
and for good reasons since well there
was a some controversy at the end but
not really what I mean by this is that
we're going to explain that when we
check out the game so without further
ado Alireza with the white pieces opens
with E 4 we have E 5 by Magnus so not
going for his Sicilian we have Knight to
f3 knight c6 and Bishop to b5 the rule
opus is on the board with a 6 more fees
defense I think this is the first time
Magnus goes for this in the in the rapid
in blitz championship brush up the a4
and the d6 now the Stein into defense by
Magnus we have castles and the bush of
the b7 c 3 we have g6 preparing to fee
and capped at the dark square bishop and
the d4 magnus goes Bishop to g7 now we
have h3 and the Knight to f6 so this is
all a very standard stuff but here mag
alga rest goes for Bishop to c2 a lot of
most haven't played here but not disrupt
the c2 this is a new move now but it is
possible that they will transpose it
into some game that was played after
this move is played but ok as a move 9
we have a completely new game
Magnus castles and rook to e1 so pretty
much all standard rule opus moves rook
e8 Knight B to d2 the night is now
coming to well to f1 and then to g3 or
maybe three depending on what black
plays we have Queen to e7 developing the
Queen connecting rooks and knights to f1
we have Queen back to f8 and now Magnus
will try to trade off the dark square
Bishop so with Bishop to h6
Knights the g3 and Bishop to h6 now this
is how Magnus will try to trade down
some pieces but Alireza is not
interested Knight to g5 so he keeps the
tension
Knights to d8 now Magnus will remain
over this Knight over to e6 to try and
kick away or or even trade of the night
Bishop to b3 with control of the e6
square but also attacking the f7 pawn
Knights the e6 and now at h4 again
holidays are keeping the pressure we
have rook a to d8 and now Bishop to e3
can
development now as nothing is happening
here Magnus goes back Bishop to g7 and
ali reza continues to push we have h5 so
now that the knight is no longer
protected magnus goes back bishop to h6
we have Queen to c1 adding another
defender to the night and now Knight to
g4 attacking the bishop on e3 here all
areas are captures we have Knight
captures and e6 and here Magnus finds
the very nice F captures on e6 which
prevents Alireza from trading with
Bishop captures on h6 because of Queen
captures an f2 checking each one and
Queen captures and g3 with mate to
follow so ali reza goes a rook the f1
instead and now Magnus just grabs the
bishop with Knight captures and e3
winning the bishop pair F captures and
III and Queen to e7 now we have H
captures with H captures and the Queen
to d2 now preparing to bring the other
rook into the game and now e capture
Sundy for you cannot capture with this
point here due to the pin so C capture
son d4 and King g7 now are getting away
from this from this pin rook to f3
Ali resin out prepares to double up on
the F file and now rook to f8 by Magnus
countering the rook we have rook a to f1
and now well
Magnus Magus was considering some Bishop
to b5 action but you don't really force
white to trade on f8 as Knights to e 2
will be a useful move for the night
so Magnus decides against this we have
rook captures an f3 rook captures and
adjust rook to f8 now getting rid of all
the pressure and now Magnus wants to
enjoy his bishop pair we have Queen to C
3 and here Magnus now I got all over run
time than other days that he had to
think things through
as the c7 ponies under attack and also
you have to take this check into
consideration so Magnus just played c6
if you open up a discovery then just be
v can be played Knights the f1 now the
e3 pawn is nicely protected the rook and
Queen can move and E 5 by Magnus we have
rook captures and f8 King captures an f8
and now Queen to see for a threatening
the sneaky Queen to g8 made since the
Queen prevents cousin from escaping
Queen to f6 freeing up the e7 square for
across since King and now Quinjet check
doesn't really do anything King just
mostly 7
that's all there is so he captures on e5
instead d characters and now Queen to b4
with check checking the king and
attacking the b7 point so Carson miss
this and he didn't feel glad it's a bit
well it's basically one ring upon which
pretty much the same as he did against
noted back so he played c5 here he would
like to give up this point instead of
this pawn so after check then move the
King or block with the Queen but Ali
Rezai still grabs this one as it messes
up call since pawn structure and now we
have Bishop the b1 b5 threatening f1
Queen to c8 with check we and now the
problem is you cannot go here because of
Queen to g8 mate so Carson has to go
King to e7 and now ali reza grabs the c5
pawn as well with Czech king the Queen
the d6 blocking and now a little just
rates we have captures captures and even
though cross and it has the bishop
repair he's down
two points but holidays I has a double D
pawn still white white is definitely
better here
Bishop to f7 attacking the pawn king
upon 2 G upon 2 g5 but not yet first
Magnus straights Bishop captures and you
cannot move the knight if you don't want
to lose the e3 pawn with check that's
why I shoved f7 was played Bishop
captures King captures now Magnus goes
into the opposite color Bishop Bishop
endgame where he's down upon but he's a
confident that he will be able to hold
this since white is able to only create
one passport so g5 we've kinked e 2 and
now Bishop to f8 now Carlson has to
create a strategy how to hold this
position with King to f3 King to e7
attacking the bishop bishop back to c4
and now a 5 putting the point to a nice
dark square King e 2 and the King to d6
now we have Bishop back to d5 and the
Bishop to e7 so this is the the
structure that Carlsen will use to hold
but King to f3 now now the king is
coming to f5 and this could pose some
problems for Magnus with Bishop to d8
cross intend to do anything he just has
to wait came to g4 and now better of the
e7 not often that that Magnus finds
himself in such a position position with
King a5 Bishop back to d8 and
G for now Bushra back the seven crossing
just has to wait a three preparing to
create a passed pawn with b4 and you
can't blow a crater blockade because a
four is a light square white will very
easily pick it up with the bishop so
rush up to D 8 B 4 now a character say
captures alga Reza has successfully
created a passed pawn with Bishop to e7
and now he continues to push we have b5
worship the d8 by Magnus holding the b6
square while also holding the pawn here
and here we have King to g6 by ali riza
both of them were extremely low on time
here King to c5 by Magnus going after
the pawn and now King to f5 again
threatening to grab the pawn here and
Magnus captures it we have King capture
some b5 King captures on e5 and kink the
c5 now we have king te 6 now it's hard
for for cross and scheme to get back
into the game Bishop to a5 and now now
we have a 5 with Bishop to b2 by Magnus
and now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for a liras
that while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
King to f7 it's the the move that wins
for those of you who also who want to
enjoy the show point is that now this is
the threat you cannot well that the King
blocks the dark square so you cannot
block with the bishop first you have to
capture the Bishop e6 then Bishop before
you guard e7 pawn but it's not a pe7
square but it's not a problem
East 7 captures captures and now after
King e5 you will simply win the pawn
king f7 and now the two points prevent
the King from going any further you're
gonna have to go for the e pawn and I'll
just king g6 captures captures and of
course now this is completely winning
for white however after a cross since
Bishop to d2 Alireza automatically
defends it with e4 and this gives
Coulson a very important temple worship
to c3 now you cannot go king of seven
because Magnus just picks up the e5 pawn
so kink the f5 by allah reza kink the b6
magnus has to go around as well all of
these squares are covered so he has to
go all the way around and here again ali
reza misses the opportunity for king
captures on g5 because after bishop
character
skin goes back and now you will have to
connect it well to past points to push
which is of course completely winning
but ali reza pushes East six we have
King to c7 and now king to g6 we have
King to d8 by Magnus and now King
captures and g5 so now yes you have all
these past pawns but now Carson's King
is much more active here across and
played into East seven with King to h5
and then out Bishop to d2 we have g5 by
ali reza Bishop to f4 and now kink the
g4 also a weird decision well it is a g6
is just winning here because after
Bishop to e5 you have King h6 just
guarding the the g7 square King f8 you
just push East 7 bring the King back g7
Bishop picks it up you capture and of
course now you have a pawn and and the
bishop of course completely winning but
in the heat of battle with a few seconds
on the clock ali reza goes King G for
kicks the bishop away
Magnus plays Bishop to b2 and here ali
reza was constantly knocking down pieces
and he was losing a lot of time putting
them back and here i believe he knocked
down his own bishop and then he went to
press the clock but you're not allowed
to press the clock if any if all of the
pieces are not in their places if you
knock them down so while it has affixed
them hit the clock but it hit zero zero
zero so here it was in this position
that oh it has a frozen lost in time why
did he lose in time some say that of
course it's it should be a draw because
magnets cannot win this game but it's
actually not true if it has a place the
absolute worst moves here he Magnus can
win this game for example if Magnus did
not have this bishop I don't know if the
interface doesn't allow me to hide it if
this was the position then it's a draw
but with the bishop here across and can
still deliver mate I'm not going a
concurring to demonstrate how
Magnus can deliver mate here it's pretty
it's a helpmate or a self mate I don't
know what's it called but it is possible
for example King f5 King to f8 a let's
say King g6 Bishop to f4 let's say e 5
now White has to play the absolute worst
moves the Bishop captures on e5 King h7
Bishop to b2 now let's say best of the
efore bishop
a three kink the 88 we're gonna play
Bishop to b4 not Bishop to h7 and here
Magnus has worshipped S III with
checkmate as well the King is covering
both of these squares and the light
square bishop blocks white from moving
so this is why Carlsen wins this game
and it's not a draw because a checkmate
is possible and the rule state that no
one expects you not to play the worst
moves possible so that's that's why this
is a win and not a draw as so many of
you were were wondering why this is the
case of course in such a top-tier
competition when the course and phases
ferrata of course it is impossible for
all areas that get checkmated like this
but would you you know impossible is a
very heavy word and the rochester
history a lot of things that you know
should have been impossible were over
were very possible so yeah that's why
this is a win and a very important win
for Magnus Carlsen in the very tough
loss for Ali Reza I think someone wrote
in the comments that ali reza also
reported Magnus for for not I don't know
what you reported him for but after a
Magnus blundered upon that he didn't
behave well so I don't know if that will
be taken into account or will this
remain I went for Magnus but for now at
least before I started recording this
video this the win was aboard awarded to
Magnus so it will be it will be a tough
tough tough game but rules are rules and
this really helps him win his third
world championship title so tough tough
break for alga Reza but what are you
gonna do there were so many chances for
him to just win the game and even though
he's a monster player he he really just
crushed Magnus here yeah once again an
example of why it's extremely important
to always always study the endgame so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank we
quite ran a glib cop chunk of Joseph
Matt er now Hamid Masucci and the TAS or
some passes for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
most likely one more game from the world
blitz championship to see if Magnus will
be able to take take home the Triple
Crown and then of course we're gonna go
through all your suggestions and check
any of the games that I
I have missed so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day